yeah it's really interesting and that's
not that is absolutely not to say that
specialists aren't important right no
absolutely not in fact I like to
highlight the NPR in our public radio
did a review of range and they they say
that I spend a lot of time giving credit
to dissenters which which I like because
not even dissenters like I agree we need
specialists also I like the way that
that the physicist and mathematician
Freeman Dyson and and great writer
framed it he said we need frogs and
birds frogs are down in the mud looking
at all the little details birds are up
above they can't see those details but
they can integrate the information of
frogs and he said the problem is we're
telling everybody to become frogs and
and when that when you know when
disciplines and science changes that
that becomes a big problem that's sort
of how I I think of it and so so I think
you need like these problems that stump
two people at Lille obviously they were
solving a lot of problems on their own
they were posting the ones that they got
stuck so I think with the combination of
that of the in descent of approach and
those specialists that's where you get
the best of both worlds and you have
this healthy problem-solving ecosystem
I'm joined by David Epstein all the way
from the opposite side of the Atlantic
and we're talking about range today how
are you David um well thanks for having
me you're all over the place at the
moment right your busy guy yes I'm quite
awesome I'm getting sick a little bit of
my own voice yeah yeah well I thankfully
for the listeners I don't think that
they will be so well we'll get it dig
into your new book today range right
talking about generalists and
specialists yeah absolutely
why why did you write the book first off
you know it sort of it sort of came the
genesis of it came in sort of two parts
one of which was I wrote a book before
this called the sports gene about
genetics and athleticism and I as well
as Malcolm Gladwell would say I devoted
several pages to criticizing his work
that's how he puts it to basically
criticizing the science underlying the
10,000 hour rule and so we got invited
to this conference here called the MIT
Sloan Sports analytics conference it's
founded by the general manager of the
Houston Rockets and we were invited
there to debate 10,000 hours versus the
sports gene and it's oh it's on YouTube
you can see it oh wow and he's very
clever and I didn't wanna get
embarrassed so so it did my homework try
to anticipate what he would argue you
know and thinking all right well he's
got to argue for early specialization
it's it's kind of implicit in some of
the things he's written and so I went
and looked at at science of athletic
development and saw that in fact in most
sports and in most places of the world
athletes who go on to become elite have
a so-called sampling period where they
play a variety of sports they gain he's
brought general skills they learn about
their interests and abilities and they
actually delay specializing until later
than peers who plateau at lower levels
and I sort of brought that up in the
debate and he said oh you know you know
what you later you know what you kind of
got me on was that thing you should you
should write more about that and I sort
of filed it away in the back of my head
and didn't think about it much more for
you know more than a year and then I was
doing some work with a foundation here
in the you giving a talk to some
military veterans who'd been given
scholarships by this foundation called
the Pat Tillman
Foundation to aid them in new career
trajectories and I talked a little bit
about late specialization in sports and
since they weren't athletes I sort of
tacked on a little bit of research about
the work world and they were so
enthusiastic about it because they were
all career changing they'd been told
they were behind and all these things
that it was like you know they just
wanted more and more and more and they
all wanted to follow up and keep in
touch and I sort of said these people
had these incredible experiences you
know some former Navy SEALs and all this
kind of stuff and they're being told
like that they're behind you know
instead of how they can wield those
experiences and so I sort of thought
alright there's there's something worth
doing here yes how did the debate with
Malkin go d-did you draw was it to
deduce the draw how do you think it went
you know first of all I think we have
more common ground than 10,000 hours
versus the sports gene to be quite
honest and we were so it's on YouTube
people can see that but we had a we were
invited back in March to the same
conference and we went again and this
time it was it wasn't framed as a debate
just as a discussion and it this one's
on YouTube too and in mini 54 he says
you know I I now feel a little
differently I think I've conflated two
ideas the idea that you need a lot of
practice to become good with the idea
that in order to become good at X you
should do only X and only X starting as
early as possible and I think one of
those is true the other is not and I
think I conflated them so now my ideas a
little different and I thought that was
you know a great way to sort of update
the the mental model and he's super
open-minded guy that we both learned
things from our discussions and that was
our recent discussion in that that's
sort of where he's out where he's at on
it so I mean if you've managed to change
Malcolm Gladwell's mind and he's
somewhere on the book right like he gave
like the world's greatest blurb I think
it says something like you know for
reasons I can't explain David makes me
enjoy the experience of being told
everything I thought about something was
wrong or something like that which of
course everything he thought about it
isn't wrong but but you know what he's
he's he he's saying yeah I get it that's
um that's a big accolade from a very
very well respected guy in that field so
moving on to the book itself where does
it begin where do we start with range
yeah so it's because because it's sort
of you know one of the seeds of its
Genesis was in the sports world that's
that's kind of where it begins because
when we were having that first debate we
sort of talked about this what we kind
of framed is the Roger versus tiger
problem so everyone knows the tiger
Woods story but maybe they don't know it
but you've absorbed the gist of it
probably which is that you know he
specialized very very young his father
gave him a putter when he was seven
months old and he dragged it around his
little baby Walker not not trying to
make him into a golfer but just like
giving him something to play with you
know and but but he was very physically
precocious and by ten months he was
imitating a swing he'd seen his father
practicing and two years old this is
also on YouTube two years old he's he's
on a national television show showing
off his golf swing in front of Bob Hope
who's sort of a famous television
personality here you know I three his
father his father at this point realizes
there's something very unusual at 3:00
he starts sort of media training him you
know playing a reporter and having him
answer some questions and you know
fast-forward the age of 21 he becomes
the best golfer in the world and from a
very young age was like there's some
there's some sort of cute interview
clips of him saying like you know I'm
gonna be Jack Nicklaus or whatever when
he's four years old basically so on the
other end of the spectrum was Roger
Federer who was also you know a gifted
athlete clearly from the time he was
young but played dabbled in swimming
skiing wrestling handball basketball
tennis table tennis badminton soccer a
little bit of rugby I think I'm missing
one but anyway bunch of stuff mother
mother was a tennis coach refused to
coach him because he like wouldn't
return balls normally you know I kind of
want to do his own thing and and even
when even when he was getting really
good and and the coaches suggested he
move up to older play with older players
he declined because he liked talking
about you know pro wrestling with his uh
with his friends after practice and he
didn't have any of those ideas that I'm
gonna be you know like the Tiger Woods
did I'm gonna be Jack Nicholas or
whatever he so when he got good enough
to warrant an interview with a local
newspaper and they asked him if he ever
became a pro what would he buy with his
first paycheck
he said Mercedes and his mother was
appalled
by this and asked the reporter if she
could hear the recording of it and the
reporter obliged and it turned out he'd
actually said Mayer CDs and Swiss German
accent he just wanted more CDs not not a
Mercedes so he was he it was different
so he said in 2006 when they were both
dominating everything Roger sort of said
like his you know I've never met someone
who's so familiar with this feeling of
being kind of invincible but his story
is completely different than mine and so
the question was sort of which one of
these is more nor normal because we know
the Tiger Woods story and we've we've
extrapolated from that story to all of
these other areas of life we don't
really hear the Roger Federer story that
much and which is the norm and it turns
out that the Federer story is is far
more typical especially in non golf
sports is that true
I'd have been surprised I think upon
hearing about specialisation versus
generalization you immediately hark to
Henry Ford right and like that event of
what capitalism has been specializing in
there you hear all the time like one of
the first things that I was told when I
started this podcast I was looking
online at what the status quo was for
how you do a podcast and what you should
do one of the first things niche down
like niche down as hard as you can and
then expand out from there etc etc so
yeah there's definitely a pervasive
acceptance of nashing down hard
big specialization early on compound
like then leverage the compounding
interest that you get on top of that one
thing being because if you start ten
years later than that that's ten years
of compounding interest that you haven't
got on that particular skill but yeah it
seems like there's potentially an
alternative route yeah I mean in the
podcast world I mean that meant make
some sense to me right cuz there's so
much competition right now for podcasts
like you compared to my last book which
came out six years ago I mean the number
of podcasts invitations I've gotten like
there must been an exponential explosion
in podcast since then and I think that
makes a lot of sense and that's sort of
that sort of gets to a couple of issues
one of which is that the the difference
between a generalist and a specialist is
semantics right and it's like they're
what even is it like you know it's just
a matter of degree in semantics
and in the book I talk about his
interesting studies of inventors of
technological inventors and and
basically what these studies show is
that they're there in this case there
actually is sort of a label for
generalist and specialist and and the
researchers usually do it by looking at
patents and you'll say okay the
specialists over their career have their
patents in a more named aller number of
technological domains the US Patent and
Trademark Office has four hundred and
fifty different technological domains
and then they have all these sub domains
and so the specialist will usually stay
in one or very few of those classes the
generalist might be in lots of them may
be dozens of them even right and so the
question in some of this research was
which of these people makes the bigger
contributions technology and and the
answer was basically the specialists
make contributions and the generalists
make contributions then there are these
sort of dilettante who don't have a lot
of depth or breadth and they don't make
major contributions yeah and then the
biggest contributions come from what
they called the polymath who who starts
grounded in a certain area and then over
the course of their career begins
sacrificing some more depth for breath
yeah so they they do start in this area
and they can continue they and they they
could go either path when they have a
grounding in one area and they could
start going broad right away or they
could drill down right away and what
they do is is they they you know get
some firm footing in that one area and
then they start going broad and like
combining these different realms taking
knowledge from one domain and bringing
it to the other and specifically those
people do better when they're in these
sort of more amorphous technological
areas where the next questions the next
steps aren't so clear so like things
that are unexpected breakthrough so one
of the ones I one of the ones I talked
about in the book is this thing called
multi-layer optical film which I know
that sounds like technical but but I
like this example because it is in
everything it's in your cell phone it's
in your computer and it's it's basically
these layers of polymers or plastics
that can be tailored to reflect and
refract light in certain ways and so
that instead of being absorbed by your
screen or coming out of the screen it
will bounce around and get recycled and
so you need less battery power in order
to keep the screen bright and all these
sorts of things and the inventor who led
the team that discovered that sort of
said you know I was told all my career
to become a specialist in in his
particular field and he said you know
what nobody told me was that I should
also learn all of the adjacent stuff
like all these other types of like
technologies around it and that's that's
really what gave him his breakthrough
learning all this stuff that was outside
of his specialty and kind of bringing it
into things that he knew better an even
more more generalist level one of the
stories I liked was a guy named gunpei
Yokoi who didn't do well in his
electronics exams in Japan so he had to
settle for kind of a low tier job as a
machine maintenance worker at a playing
card company and the students who did
better on the electronics exam wanted
big companies in Tokyo and he had to be
in this playing card company in Kyoto
and he realized he was not really
equipped to work on the cutting edge and
but that there was a lot of information
easily available that as people were
sort of racing to to the cutting edge
they were leaving behind and that you
could combine it in ways that
specialists kind of couldn't see and so
he started doing that and went from
being a machine maintenance worker just
tinkering around starting a toy and game
operation at that company and the
company called Nintendo which was
started as a 19th century playing card
company no way and he started the first
toy and game development operation and
and did use that strategy to create the
Game Boy which was outdated processor
you know screen it looks like rotten
salad or something for a great sale for
grayscale shades of graphics right and
came out right when Sega and Atari came
out with color versions of the same
thing but what he knew so his philosophy
he translates to lateral thinking with
withered technology and what he meant by
that was lateral thinking meaning taking
you know knowledge from one area where
it's sort of ordinary and bringing it
somewhere else we're not pushing the
cutting edge but taking knowledge from
across and bringing it somewhere else
and by whithered technology he meant
stuff that's already well understood and
cheaper so you don't have the you don't
need a specialist I for like what are
going to be the developmental you know
hurdles
that became like a core philosophy for
for Nintendo and you know I think it's I
think it's pretty cool in fact when when
one of his colleagues came to him he
recounted this when the gameboy was
gonna come out and said bad news say can
Atari have there's like coming out right
at the same time and Yokoi said are they
color and his colleague says yes and
he's like then we're fine no problem
because what he realized was that the
the barrier to getting more customers
was not the competing on the quality of
the graphics necessarily or the color it
was you know affordability durability
battery life all these things so game
boys were practically indestructible
yeah during the research of this book I
found one of my parents basement had
batteries that expired 2007 and I
flipped it on and played Tetris for a
couple minutes it's still an
indestructible ugly indestructible yet a
wet you know you leave it out dry out it
comes back and also because the
technology was well understood they were
able to pump out tons of games really
quickly like yeah both internally and
from external developers you know it's
almost like making a platform or app
developers could start making stuff
quickly because they already knew all
this technology and so that was a real I
mean he was like a pure sort of
generalist inventor but but I think the
in some of the other research it was
sort of that those those polymath
inventors who have their area of
expertise but then they they kind of
understand things that are adjacent to
it yeah it sounds like there's a lot of
frontiers that you've gone into with
this considering as you say the sports
gene focused on athletics and yeah
boards where is now we're talking
industry were talking professionals
individual career multiple career sports
again yeah you know all that sort of
stuff there's a lot of different ways to
go here I don't I'm going to guess
considering how busy oh I'm going to
guess that you won't have heard Navarre
rather [ __ ] on Joe Rogan yet no I
haven't but I know that he's you know I
know who he is I haven't heard about Joe
Rogan no okay have you consumed much of
his content not a lot no okay well I
mean he is he's a real force to be
reckoned with he's the real deal man and
I highly recommend anyone who's
listening and yourself go check it out
with fantastic podcast Joe Rogan's most
recent one with an eval and
he says the greatest pleasure in life
for me is learning something from one
industry and then layering it onto a
latticework of things from other
industries he too is talking about it in
the in the context of people who virtue
signal with the number of books that
they're reading or that they've read and
look at how many books I've gone through
this that and the other and Navarre is a
big proponent of reading a book until he
gets something that he likes and then
just putting it down and then maybe you
go back to it five years later like he
just wants to have I think one of the
things that's interesting with that is
he read a lot as a kid his mother used
to drop him off at the library after
school because he lived in like a pretty
rough area in New York I think and she'd
leave him at the library he read
everything in the library like
dictionaries religious books magazines
whatever it was and so he's coming at it
from someone who has big base of
knowledge and now because of that is
able to take all these different
concepts piece them together and has the
perspective the broad perspective where
he's able to make connections that other
people aren't I thought that was I
thought that was super interesting
that's interesting Anna you mentioned a
number of really interesting things and
I'm interested to hear this too because
some people have lost track of my like
Twitter now is the inboxes I'm losing
track of my various inboxes but um this
is good because some people tweeted at
me about invol and some of them were
like I wonder what he thinks about this
because he advocates for only
specialised knowledge and then others
were like this sounds like it works with
wouldn't've all says about combining
knowledge I'm like ah I don't know the
degree are disagree like leaders he
contains multitudes maybe I'd had a
difficult guy to put into a box I think
that probably actually identifies the
key element of why people like Navarre
that he is a walking contradiction right
like he's this angel CEO AngelList CEO
like venture capitalist investor spends
a lot of time in Silicon Valley spends a
lot of time in Silicon Valley but isn't
massively left-leaning it's just normal
libertarian he doesn't have like that
ruthless capitalists streak to him and
is all about inner peace
that most of the first bit of joe rogan
is him talking about how do we achieve
happiness you need to care about your
family in this than the other
that's totally contrary to what you
expect from lying the CEO of this big
company right he's just a walking
paradox that's interesting is oh sorry
go ahead I mean interrupt it's just
that's it he's he's difficult to put
into a box and I think when that happens
the cognitive dissonance sort of starts
firing in people's heads a little bit
and what happened they don't know how to
interpret him and I guess that actually
when we're talking about generalists
versus specialists for me personally I
like having a multi-faceted life I like
having a multi-faceted personality I
like not being a trope of myself
no wait yeah I'm right I'm writing
things down because you're getting to so
many things that I wanted a couple
things so so so one about involved this
reminds me you know not to like turn
people to books other than my own but
they should read books other than my
range right obviously but but that
reminds me of this book that I really
loved called wired to create by Scott
Barry Kaufman and Carolyn Gregoire
because basically one of the themes is
that these creative people are like
contradictory and all their personality
tests basically like they contain
multitudes you know and so they will
display these sort of like beliefs and
values and personality traits that you
usually assume are in contradiction
basically and so that was like one of my
main learnings from that book so it's
really interesting to hear that it also
reminds me of you know I spend some time
in range on scientists for a number of
reasons one because I'm interested in
them too because I used to be in
training to be a scientist so I mean you
know I was like living in a tent in the
Arctic when I decided for sure I was
gonna become or try to become a writer
and so I didn't realize at the time that
like grad school in environmental
science where I was totally ordinary
scientist then when I get to like Sports
Illustrated suddenly that knowledge is
extraordinary most like well advanced
scientist in the room right totally so
so is that sort of combination but also
scientists you know in the sweep of
humanity scientists are specialized like
no doubt about it but but I kind of
to show that even within that look at
the benefits you get of broadening more
than you you know where everyone's
saying you could just be more
specialised of even being broader and
and in that chapter that talks about
that there's this research that looks at
which scientific papers go on to make
the biggest impacts and the biggest
impact papers you raise the chances of a
paper becoming high impact if it has
what's called an atypical combination of
knowledge which essentially the
researchers look at journals that appear
in the citations of papers and if if the
paper makes has citations of journal
pairs that have never appeared in other
papers before which typically means
because they're coming from different
disciplines basically that raises the
chances of it be eventually becoming an
high-impact paper by a lot most papers
no matter what they do don't become
high-impact papers of course because
it's very small but in if it has two
atypical combinations of knowledge then
it's really much more likely to have
that so it's sort of similar to that
right it's like making these sort of
combinations of knowledge that that
aren't typically made makes it a much
higher chance of becoming one of these
these hit papers basically yeah one of
the things I'm thinking so we've
discussed we've kind of I guess Joe one
working so hit me hit me okay
he mentioned not be a trope up you're
yourself you know and after the sports
team came out that was sort of a
surprise success for me and worried
about being pigeon-holed after that I
guess I wasn't worried about it because
I was because because one outwardly it's
fine for people to pigeonhole me like if
if I do something that's more valuable
to readers or more interesting to them
and that's what they identify me with
that's fine
the pigeonholing I'm concerned about is
like the things that I want to do right
so if I'm viewed as being in a
pigeonhole I don't mind that so much but
I don't want to actually be in a
pigeonhole in my daily life you can
break out let anything that you do
presuming that you don't then take the
particular label that you've been
lumbered with and feel like you have
some sort of duty to follow that along
great don't do that you're actually like
just a perfect example is what we're
talking about now like I wrote a poem I
wrote a book on sports now
gonna bring one out that kinda touches
on sports but touches on loads of other
stuff as well like [ __ ] you I'm gonna do
what I want like and if the people from
the sports gene come along for the ride
then fantastic I mean the advice was
basically to write the sports gene to
right away after the sports gene it was
yeah do it again brand yourself as the
Sports Science Guy and cetera etc etc
commercialize yeah two weeks after that
book came out I left Sports Illustrated
and went to a job that has nothing to do
with sports at this place called Pro
Publica
that's just you know I'm doing reporting
on drug cartels and stuff like that so
like you know several years after the
book came out I was still gonna
introduce places as reported Sports
Illustrated haven't been there in four
years you know and so but an inmate
maybe if I branded myself as a sports
science guy and wrote sports gene to I
don't know the counterfactual like maybe
financially I would have been more
successful I really don't know but it is
absolutely now what I wanted to do and I
feel that things obviously have been
going well with this book and you know
there were chapters on art and music and
those researching those chapters ignited
interest for me that really changed the
way I go to a museum or listen to a
concert so it really has added to my
life in a very material way just like
doing the the exploration and I think
that's one of the ways that you know we
kind of get into this sort of work where
we we talk to people with unfamiliar
ideas because we're interested in a lot
you know yeah so thinking about the
outcomes I want to go back to the actual
process of how we talk about
specializing at the beginning and then
moving on it being a generalist later on
and the actual sort of nitty-gritty
about that so I'm sure a lot of people
are looking for some prescriptions and
some heuristic that how they can apply
that to their own lives you know one of
the things that I think when we're
talking about the outcomes that we've
discussed so far I wonder you talked
about high impact papers having these or
you can use that as a simulacrum or a
representation for other things right
like that there are some people who will
have generalized and then specialized
and had a big impact at such as yeah I
wonder whether the distribution in terms
of the most optimal approach as abroad
for a broad cross-section of people I
wonder whether you get winners and
losers with the
generalization and whether you get more
okay performances with the
specialization did you have a look at
anything like that I'll consider it
that's a good question and I think in
some ways it's sort of domain dependent
and let me let me explain why I I think
that so I introduced this concept in the
book that the of different types of
learning environments what the
psychologist Robin Hogarth calls kind
and wicked learning environments and
kind learning environments are where all
the information is freely easily
available human behavior is usually not
as involved very much next steps are
clear you get automatic feedback when
you do something and that feedback is
fully accurate so you can think of golf
as something like this or chess you know
and it's based on repetitive patterns
and so in a lot of areas like if you
read some of the underlying sort of
10,000 hours type research a lot of the
advantage of specialized experts has to
do with types of pattern recognition
basically so they learn to pick up these
patterns in an unconscious way that it
allows them to make certain types of
decisions and in chess
for example that works like rocket fuel
like early specialization works in chess
in fact if you haven't started studying
those patterns by the age of 12 your
chances of reaching international master
status which is like one down from
grandmaster drops from like one in four
like one in fifty five or something like
that so it works the thing is those
domains also tend to be the easiest to
automate because of those unchanging
rules and based on repetitive patterns
and easy feedback and things like that
so the reason the chess you know
computers got so good at chess so
quickly is because it's a kind of
learning environment if you as you get
more wicked so think of like from
computer chess to self-driving cars
where there's lots of rules lots of
recurring situations and yet it's the
sort of unusual things that have kept us
from being able to fully implement them
and now people are talking about well
maybe we implement them only in certain
areas that have certain rules and stuff
like that and then to the far end of the
spectrum which is like medical research
where IBM's Watson has has
underperformed so badly that some of the
AI researchers I was talking to were
concerned that it would like damage the
reputation of
I in healthcare I don't even know I
haven't even heard that story yeah yeah
so one of the one of the doctor
scientists I was speaking with said the
reason Watson
you know destroyed a jeopardy and
totally failed in cancer research is
because we know the answers to jeopardy
so so it's a different challenge so so
some of it has to do with the domain
you're in so I think some of the domains
that are most amenable to narrow
specialization also become the easiest
to automate so so that's a so that can
create some serious losers huge nose
huge using yourself I guess therefore
suggests generalist is the way to go in
those realms but but I also think you're
right that with generalization there are
some some winners and losers right
because for some people it means that
they may end up looking a lot more like
a dilettante okay so like LinkedIn did
some research recently that looked at
what predicts who becomes an executive
and they have convey of these enormous
databases you know so instead of study
of like 20 people who this study was
half a million people and the number one
number one best predictor was if you
went to a top five Business School
program which okay it met my guess is
that that's not causal because of the
schools because it's selecting for
people who are already doing quite well
you know and but the next predictor was
the number of different job functions
you had worked across within an industry
so each different job functions saved
about three years of experience on route
to going to become an executive so that
that's very different than what we think
of right is telling people like bounce
around direction yeah so the chief
economist smade recommendation since
sake recommending someone like go to a
top five Business School like that's not
such a useful recommendation because
that's not open to everyone and and
inexpensive and all that and but so his
top recommendation was to work across a
large number of job functions which is
not the advice that you usually hear and
I now bet for some people that makes
them ending up looking like a dilettante
where it's kind of like well you haven't
really learned anything that well and
for other people they're the most likely
to become the executives and so so I
think there probably is some of that
winner and loser and in
and I think so I was just at a sorry I'm
this is related but I'm sorta can I have
an aggressive brain wherever you want to
go David we're going down the rabbit
hole with you monk okay I was at this
conference of the people are interested
in investing and you know what do I know
but they invited me to the conference to
just and you're just the guy who doesn't
doesn't have a clue sign the corner
they'll be me right we'd be sitting
together but so and they put up before I
went up they took something from my book
and did a poll for the audience you know
they could vote on their cell phones
okay and and the poll was what do you
think is the average age of a founder of
a blockbuster startup on the day of the
founding of the company okay and I think
the choices were 25 35 45 55 and 25 was
the overwhelming answer well mark Mark
Zuckerberg said once all old people are
stupid right all young people are clever
young people are just smarter that's it
yeah right he was 22 years old when he
said that so he had an interest in
saying that okay and and but the actual
answer there's just some some pretty new
research from MIT and Northwestern and
the US Census Bureau that showed the
average age is actually about forty five
and a half and that's that's not when
the company becomes breakthrough it's
the day of founding right so these
people at this event who really pay
attention to all this investing stuff
were overwhelmingly he was like 70% they
thought 25 and I think the reality is
that those startup founders often have
to do some zigzagging and they end up
with these sort of unique groups of
skills where it makes sense for them to
go compete on their own ground and try
to start it up something new because
they have these sort of intersecting
skills and obviously startups are high
risk high failure high reward and all
those things but but I do think you can
be a big winner or a big loser as a
generalist how much do you think as you
discussing that there one of the things
that comes to mind is diminishing
margins of return so thinking about as
someone specialises down there is only
so much better that you can get at
something anyone who's tried
weightlifting or powerlifting knows
to pee be within your first your pee be
in every week in your first year of like
going to the gym right but then after
ten years of training for you to add
like five kilos on to your total it
needs a ungodly amount of preparation
and people are working at the very
margins of their performance right so
there's a question of maybe you can get
more bang by incorporating a new skill
where you're on the lower end of the
learning curve still and I think that's
that's interesting but there's two
things even even aside from diminishing
returns you can actually start to have
really perverse effects from increasing
specialization so so surgeons is an area
where I mentioned in the book that
specialized surgeons have fewer
complications period they do that's good
so a few problems you have problems
right that's right fewer problems
specialized searches and and even if you
account for the either experience the
number of times they've done the surgery
specialized surgeons still do better so
there's something on top of just
experience about being a specialized
surgeon that makes them even better I
don't know what it is interest but
that's that's the finding and so if you
need to have surgery you know you want a
specialized surgeon at the same time
specialized surgeons tend to do a huge
number of procedures that don't need to
be done at all such that you know if you
they're these these studies eyesight
where if you have to check into a
hospital with a heart problem you're
you're less likely to die and this is a
course these are us-based studies if you
check in on the dates of a national
cardiology conference because you're
less likely to get some of these
intervention procedures that you may die
with all right so the the cardiologists
who wrote the editorial for this study
said my my colleagues and I would joke
that this is the safest place to have a
heart problem in our conference in this
study really turns that on its head and
suggests that a lot of unnecessary
procedures are done because the the
specialist will get this sort of when
all you have is a Hammer Every Problem
looks like a nail syndrome and so
they're really good at the procedure but
they'll also continue to do it even even
after even after science shows that like
it unequivocally should not be done any
more there's a whole book about this
called ending medical reversal by these
two doctors that talks about how
procedures keep being done even after
science has like totally show they
should not be done and
more so why do they keep being done is
it people's kind of they passionate or
like feel some sort of sense of
patriotism to the procedures it's a good
question and I kind of wrote an article
about this at Pro Publica called when
evidence says no and doctors say yes and
and I thought at first that it would be
the simple case of you know when you pay
someone to do one thing it's hard to get
them to do something else but you know
if they get paid for procedures but a
very prominent hospital here said okay
we're going to uncouple payment from
procedures for this particular kind of
procedure of placing a stent where you
put like a tube in an in a blood vessel
and open it up when it's been narrowed
and if someone's having a heart attack
like you know it'll save their life but
this was particularly for people who
just come in with stable coronary artery
disease or stable chest pain basically
and a number of randomized trials have
shown that it doesn't work for that like
it doesn't is not better than just these
like less invasive therapies and when
when this prominent hospital decoupled
compensation from the procedure it still
didn't solve the problem and someone
else did a study just sort of a
psychological study of doctors who were
doing these procedures and what they
basically found was that they didn't
believe these randomized controlled
trials and they would say like patient
comes in with chest pain they have a
narrowed artery
obviously I fix it by opening it up
right like it makes sense what they call
bio plausible makes a ton of sense yeah
but but turns out that the we didn't
design the human body it's not a kitchen
sink it's much more complicated than
that and so when specialists are using
what nin you now call medicines
surrogate markers they are fixing one
piece of a puzzle and assuming that it
affects the total outcome of this larger
system but in fact in many cases what
they're doing is you know lowering
someone's blood pressure and and then
people die of heart attack and stroke at
the exact same rates with lower blood
pressure numbers and so you really need
someone looking at the outcomes you
actually care about not just at these
surrogate markers which are one small
piece of the of the whole puzzle that's
super interesting
so going more towards I guess the
nitty-gritty of the heuristics of how
people can apply some of this sort of
stuff to their own life whether they be
a an athlete or a profession
or someone that's just looking to
advance themselves through life with
some skills I'm currently reading a
number of books that kind of all fit
into this scott hates young's ultra
learning I've got a pre-release of that
there's a lot of stuff that he obviously
he's super specialized and he did the
the MIT computer science course of three
years in six months hmm then he went and
upgraded his ability to do portraits of
people like 100x to that in the space of
thirty days so he's period izing
specialization but over a broader
timespan is actually being a generalist
yeah
that that gets it something that in in
most of the people I highlight in range
are not like what we think of in from
like the Renaissance where it's like oh
there's these there's virtue in just
being like you know a Renaissance person
and doing all these different things and
it's much more that they are on the hunt
for what economists call match quality
the degree of fit between your abilities
and your interests and the work that you
do and the way that they find that is by
by zigzagging so this this woman who
studies people's career fit that I
talked about in Ranger named Herminia
Ibarra she's actually at the London
Business School and she has this saying
I love today we learned who we are in
practice not in theory and what she
means is that there are all these
personality quizzes and kind of career
gurus that that's just that we can just
introspect and and go forth you know and
like a commencement speech it's like
picture who you're gonna be in ten or
twenty years and March confidently
toward it when in fact the research
suggests that actually we have to do
stuff to learn about what we're good at
and what we're interested in so he says
act and then think you'd do something
and then reflect and that's how you
learn about the world right it's sort of
like dating like early on it might seem
like you should marry the first person
you dated but once you take more data
that seems like a less good idea we
thought about careers you know the way
we thought about dating we probably
wouldn't pressure people to settle down
so quickly but those people end up doing
a sort of zigzagging in search of match
quality because once you get good match
quality your growth rate is a lot faster
and so they're not setting out to say
I'm gonna be a generalist it's that in
the process of this zigzagging of saying
here's what I am right now
you know here my skills and interest
here the opportunities in front of me
I'm gonna try this one and maybe you're
from now I'll change cuz I will have
learned something about myself and I'll
do something else and so they just end
up with these broad experiences and
skills not because they set out to do it
in many cases but because that's how
they get to their match quality spot
totally so a couple of things coming to
mind there David date is the way of the
superior man he talks about phases in
people's lives and he says that one of
the times that's a trigger for he's
talking about men but it applies to
women as well when men realize that
their time with a particular project has
gone is that something which used to
excite them no longer does and he says a
lot of people believe that you need to
kind of grit your teeth and grind
through it and that that it would appear
doesn't seem to be the case I think most
people and this is one of the main
questions that I've got and I think a
lot of people at home may be thinking
this as well the attraction of novelty
is very high and this diffuse focus
where we're constantly being distracted
by things is on an incredibly granular
level essentially generalization like
you're looking at I'm gonna do this and
I'm gonna do this then I'm gonna I'm
gonna send a text then I'll look at my
email then I'll go do this and I think
that as you scale that up over time a
lot of people may struggle to work out
when am i calling myself short from
really working hard at something which
is simply difficult but worthwhile and
rewarding and when am i making a change
to try something new when it's justified
yeah yeah and and I'm not a big advocate
of multitasking and in that sense like
most of this but this project is very
different than my last project was very
different my previous projects and
whatever my next project is that I don't
have no idea will be very different but
when I do those things I focus in on
them period I wasn't very hard yeah yeah
and so so that's a good question and I
think again to think about how many
borrows of work what are the reason she
says that when you change it's difficult
because you're change you have to change
your identity you're not just changing
your job or what you're doing and that's
a slow process and so a lot of the
people that she saw that to do it well
they sort of dip a toe into something or
they learn about somehow they get a
keyhole view into something they
meet some new person or whatever it is
and they maybe take a class and it's
sort of they see a little little by
little and then there start to realize
they have like more interest in this or
more talent for it or whatever and then
their friends start telling them like
just keep it as a hobby you don't want
to change like you know you'll get
behind and eventually get to a point
where they're like no I have to sort of
do this and so I think the way I
approach this is I set up sort of
experiments I have a little book I call
the book of experiments but where you
know the way I used to when I was a
science grad student have a book with
hypotheses now I have a hypothesis about
myself something I want to learn or
something I want to try and here's what
I'm hoping to learn here's my hypothesis
I'll give it a try and then I'll reflect
on it
that's what self-regulatory learners do
they reflect a lot on those things and
keep going forward like that and that
worked well for me in the reporting of
this book so I took I got kind of stuck
with the organization of the book and
decided to take an online fiction
writing class and like for beginners you
know and we had to do exercises like
write only with dialogue or write with
not not with dialogue at all and after
doing that it prompted me to go back
through my whole manuscript and start
stripping down all these quotes cuz I
realized I was like leaning on quotes in
a lazy way to explain information that I
should have just been writing and leave
the quotes for sort of more voice and so
that was just a little dip my toe in
that experiment but I have to say it
also ignited I was doing it to try to
try to get off this plateau a little bit
yeah but it ignited an interest that I
wasn't really that I didn't really know
I have so I'm sure I'm gonna try some
more of that now gonna be fiction but
I'm sure I'll try more of it for sure
because I think either way it made me a
better made me a better nonfiction
writer but the point is you didn't I
didn't have to like take a total right
turn like it's this or that I was able
to kind of dip my toe into it in a way
that's useful for me and so I think
those that Herminia borrows approach of
of small experiments is like a way to
try to do these things but I think they
should be done deliberately not like I'm
doing a million things at once it should
be like what do I hope to learn what am
i interested in who or what can I engage
to test that and then reflect on it and
go forward not just like scatterbrain
didn't is like proactive testing while
you're becoming broad are you familiar
with James Cleese Explorer exploit
framework yeah yeah I mean the Explorer
displayed framework as predates James
clear for sure oh that's why I've
misread it in atomic atomic habits well
yeah oh you know why he comes up James
yeah I mean you know it's old in the
business literature I don't know who
first discovered it but you have the
Explorer exploit of you know creation of
new knowledge versus ringing the most
out of out of knowledge you already have
there and when one chapter in the book
is about outside problem solvers
basically and what that means is so
there was a guy who was the VP of
research and development Lille massive
pharmaceutical company and I remember I
interviewed him he said look I'm a
specialist I'm an organic chemist if it
doesn't have a carbon in it I'm
technically not qualified to work with
it and he realized that specialists you
know they have a narrow view and a lot
of times solutions come from this
knowledge that you you couldn't have
foreseen would be important and so when
when Lily chemists got stuck on certain
problems he he went around asking so I'm
just gonna post them online and see if
anyone's and and of course they're like
that's ridiculous right we're like a
company of I don't know 120,000 people
or something with the most resources and
how does someone Excel then he said
alright give it a try
does it answers start rolling in right
another one that he liked came from
something they were stuck on was some
chemical came in from an attorney who
had worked on a patent case having to do
with tear gas or something like that and
it worked so well he spun it off into a
separate company called InnoCentive that
helps other companies post problems they
get stuck on for outside funding
problems and they try to frame the
problem in a way where it attracts
people really far away from the
discipline of the people who got stuck
and so that that's like one of
InnoCentive services and so like they
solved they helped NASA solve a problem
they'd been stuck on for 30 years with
predicting solar storms particle bursts
that can damage astronauts or equipment
and a guy who had just retired from a
cell phone company solved in six months
and at first the NASA scientists were
like no no that's a different approach
and they're like yeah that's the point
yeah and so now this guy's name is Alf
bingum who founded InnoCentive now there
have been a bunch of I don't want to say
cobby yeah just other other things like
that like one's called kaggle and that
looks for outside solvers for machine
learning program which is something you
consider really specialized but it turns
out that the people who solve those
problems you know as someone who solves
a Kegel health problem where it's
something something with data and
healthcare whatever they often aren't an
expert in machine learning and they
often aren't an expert in healthcare
either but they're like volunteers for
these as well yeah yeah yeah the
companies can post whatever kind of
reward they want this is like five
designs but for like really really
difficult stuff the listeners will be
familiar with the stephen wolfram
episode a sat down with stephen wolfram
last week with Wolfram om was an
interesting man he'd that guy is a force
I saw a lecture from him once who he's a
force of nature man like a terrifying
individual terrifying and fascinating
individual and he was saying that they
livestream like a ridiculous amount of
their calls now so it's just like you
want to know what's going on in the
Wolfram language office today cuz he's a
at home CEO right and um he's just there
he'll be on his treadmill desk treadmill
in a way and they'll be like a few
hundred a few thousand people just
watching and this I want to see there
there's it's freely available online
freely available to watch those guys
going on right and so you're talking
about this thing where people are
crowdsourcing it he is in real-time just
allowing other people on the internet
some of them I'm gonna guess he's got
like a super popular coding like
subculture fanbase right I'm gonna guess
I mean I guess that that would be you
know like me or you might have like the
sports or whatever like in the
background they'll be there might be
working away doing some stuff and they
just got Stephen Wolfram like on his
treadmill but you know there we go again
like you and but anyone can go on right
and he was saying exactly the same thing
said exactly the same thing that people
are giving them solutions from different
disciplines that they wouldn't have
thought yeah it's really interesting and
that's not - that is absolutely not to
say that specialists aren't important
right absolutely not
in fact I like to highlight the NPR in
our public radio did a review of range
and they they say that I spend a lot of
time giving credit to dissenters which
which I like because not even two
centers like I agree we need specialists
also I like the way that that the
physicist and mathematician Freeman
Dyson and and grey writer framed it he
said we need frogs and birds frogs are
down in the mud looking at all the
little details birds are up
but they can't see those details but
they can integrate the information of
frogs and he said the problem is we're
telling everybody to become frogs and
and when that when you know when
disciplines and science changes that
that becomes a big problem that's sort
of how I I think of it and so so I think
you need like these problems that
stumped to people at Lille obviously
they were solving a lot of problems on
their own they were posting the ones
that they got stuck so I think with the
combination of that of the in dissent of
approach and those specialists that's
where you get the best of both worlds
and you have this healthy
problem-solving ecosystem yeah
absolutely
how do you know if you're a frog or a
bird for the listeners at home how do
they work that out that's a that's a
great question and in a semantic issue
at some point right like if you look in
the patent research it has to do with
how many technological classes have you
worked across if you look in this comic
book research eyesight has to do with
how many different genres have you
worked across and all these sorts of
things so so you know I don't I don't
really know I don't have a perfect
answer to that although I think most
people have some intuition about it
actually but I definitely don't have a
perfect answer about it okay I don't
think that there really is going to be
one because it is so personal dependent
right yeah thinking back to some of the
things that you've said already a lot of
recent podcasts come to mind
Laura van de Kamp who wrote off the
clock she talks about and the four
disciplines of execution as well relates
to this strategizing is easy but
execution is hard the reason is that we
are forced to actually do [ __ ] if we act
like we haven't even put our money where
our mouth is as opposed to just talking
a good game and we also have paralysis
by analysis that people are so concerned
about making the wrong decision yeah
that they will hold off making any
decision I think you know Jeff Bezos
that said inaction is more costly than
action because once you start to act you
can change your course on the fly as
long as efficiently quick to move but
the Laura van de Kamp point is that she
in off the clock she talked about
committing to plans in the future it's
all about maximizing memories maximizing
your perception of time through
increasing memories and memories are
generated through intense on novel
experiences but when we get to an
evening time and we think that we might
want to go to a salsa class Netflix is
there in the beds warm and it's cold and
raining outside and she talks about
comity
to an execution and I think that when
you're talking about dipping your toe
what came to mind for me is a good
heuristic oh good tool people to use at
home is well okay just commit commit to
something in advance maybe even pay for
it but like I've always wanted to try
yoga right book a yoga class now
go on somewhere book it now and pay ten
dollars ten pounds twenty dollars
whatever it is because you're probably
going to end up going because you've
committed to it and that it might be
[ __ ] and you might hate it but you don't
know that until there's no way to know
it like your insight into yourself and
your opportunities is constrained by
your previous experiences right so if
you hate it
like I thought I was gonna be a
scientist and then I you know started
doing more lab work and I found out that
that was not the path for me but that
was the only way to find out right and
to try some of that stuff and I think
there's even an added bonus to what
you're suggesting which is that if you
look at how there's think all the end of
history illusion where we all recognize
in psychology finding that we have
changed a lot in the past based on our
experiences right the things we've gone
through and all this stuff has caused us
to change okay our values and all these
in our skills and all these things and
then we then we say but but I'm not
gonna change much in the future that's
at every time point in life we say these
these really weird results like like
people underestimate how much they'll
taste will change so if you ask someone
how much money will you pay today to see
your favorite band play ten years from
now the average answer is one hundred
and twenty nine dollars and if you ask
how much money would you pay to see your
favorite band from ten years ago today
the average answer is eighty dollars
because we underestimate like how much
our taste changes and as I was looking
at this personality research they
actually showed that one of the very
predictable changes is the Big Five
trait of openness to experience declines
as people get older okay yep and you can
actually and we know that trade is
highly associated with creativity and
you can change that decline slow it or
possibly even like reverse it somebody
just trying new stuff so these studies
that were like making seniors learn how
to do like new types of puzzles and all
these things and even if they didn't get
better at the puzzles their openness to
experience changed someone so so I think
we get in these you know we gravitate
toward things we're already comfortable
with incompetent at
and you know difficulty and trying some
new thing isn't a sign that you aren't
learning but but ease is if things if
things you're doing are too easy for you
then you're not learning things it's
weird isn't it because there is a
particular kind of mindset I've recently
started swimming and I'm like I suck
like really bad at my cardio for
swimming cardio outside of the wall and
Terra firme is not bad cardio and
swimming not so good okay but the take
off like I haven't done something that
I've stuck at consistently in his head
like linear progressive overload for a
fair while and the noob gains are
astounding and it's addictive
you're like hey this is what it's like
to do something that I'm [ __ ] crap at
like oh my god like I've got a P beat a
P meet again a period again yeah like
yeah yeah I mean I was a crap I played a
whole bunch of different sports football
basketball baseball that stuff American
football and then I ended up on running
and I ran track in college and I was a
walk-on and I sucked and then I end but
I write about this in my first book but
but I improved really rapidly and I
ended up is like a university record
holder you know and so but it was
totally addictive and in many ways I
thought I was in an easier spot than the
guys who had come in as these big-time
recruits because they had all this
pressure and it was very hard for them
to improve and I'm like improving like
crazy it's it's addictive like that and
one of the other things as well to
consider is that as you if you are going
into something new and if you're
cultivating as James clear would talk
about the the compounding effect of an
effect an effective habit over time yeah
Matt Fraser CrossFit Games champion
comes to mind there's a story in chasing
excellence by Ben Bergeron where he says
that Matt wouldn't let himself leave he
did a engineering degree I think of
mechanical engineering something like
that something like super manly at a uni
and he wouldn't lie himself leave the
library until he could likely it'll
become less manly over time yeah I know
he wouldn't let off leave the library
until he was able to complete the batum
do like an entire chapter or whatever it
was that he was learning and if he got
one thing wrong he'd force himself to
sit there and go
anything right okay roll that forward to
the sort of values that he has now yeah
and it's exactly the same like
ridiculous degree of excellence
ridiculous degree of integrity and
virtue and all the rest of the stuff
yeah I can
David today's been amazing I'm
absolutely certain that we're gonna get
requests for you to come back on so I
think you might need to hurry up and
either find some room in your schedule
or write another book quickly I'm okay
I'll find him in my schedule because I'm
not writing another book
as I set up for my last book no more
books we'll find out if two years three
years from now if I feel like I've
recovered but yeah yeah as of now I'm
saying like I did last time no more
books so maybe it'll be six years again
who knows we'll see one for the
listeners at home where can they find
you online David Epstein comm easiest
place end date and my twitter handle is
David Epstein fantastic I love a nice
short and easy to remember a handle on
yeah on all that stuff David you've been
amazing to the listeners the book range
will be linked in the show notes below
all of the other resources that we've
mentioned as well go back through and
make some cool show notes David I hope
that you survive the remainder of the
media tour I know it's been cleared for
you but I've loved this great I'm very
lucky if you are you are in your evil
but you are delivering ridiculous
volumes of very interesting stuff so it
doesn't appreciate that thank you thank
you very much
[Music]
you